welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is William Kelly professor of
anthropology and Sumitomo professor of
Japanese studies at Yale University
professor Kelly is a noted authority on
the social and historical anthropology
of Japan he has focused much of his
research in the last two decades on
regional agrarian societies in Japan
since 1996 however professor Kelley has
been conducting field research on the
history and present patterns of
professional baseball in the cities of
Osaka and Kobe today we talk with him
about sports in contemporary Japan
welcome professor Kelly thank you in the
United States we have a baseball
basketball and football give us an
overview of the sports scene in Japan as
it similar to the United States or is it
very different well that's a really
interesting question because basically
if you look at the nations of the world
and their sports capes there are two
different kinds of nations there are
countries like the United States
Australia is another example where you
have a number of different sports that
are the major center sports and they
compete and they divide up the year and
then you have a lot of other countries
mostly in Europe and the Caribbean
Brazil is another example where you have
a single sport that is the center sport
and soccer is often the center sport
there are other sports that are sort of
worked their way around that centre
sport Japan is like not the United
States but the rest of the world except
the center support is not soccer like in
England and not ice hockey like in
Canada but baseball like the United
States and it's been that way for the
entire 20th century and how did that
come to be
did they love baseball from this country
so much and brought it over there but
how what was the evolution of that well
it's actually much longer than most
people realize it goes back to the 1870s
it was in the 1860s 1868 really
Commodore Perry who opened up the
country and
we had a new government the new modern
national government they started sending
Japanese students and others abroad some
of them came to New England to Boston
there was a guy learning the railroads
in Boston they were playing baseball in
Boston he took a love to it and brought
it back to Japan and they were also
bringing teachers from the United States
and Britain to Japan to teach in the new
high schools and universities and they
were bringing cricket and rowing and a
whole lot of other Western sports
including baseball so it was a
combination of Japanese bringing it back
that Japanese worker from Boston when he
got back to Japan started a baseball
team and he wrote to none other than
Albert Spalding a very important figure
to ask him to send some bats and balls
and gloves and a rulebook which he did
so that introduced the sport already in
the 1870s it started being played in the
high schools and there was one elite
public well really private school like
Exeter and over in which there were a
number of different sports clubs that
the boys the teenagers were playing and
this was in the 1890s and by chance the
baseball club had a very ended up
beating all of the other school baseball
clubs and they looked around and there a
group of Americans down in Yokohama and
the port and they were traders and some
diplomats and sailors from the fleet in
the bay and these schoolboys kept
sending down channeling we want to come
down and play baseball with you and they
said we're a bunch of school boys we
don't really want to deal with you
finally in 1894 1896 this Yokohama teams
okay come down play us the school boys
came down the train had just been built
between Yokohama and Tokyo the first
train in Japan they took the train down
they didn't have enough money they had
to walk from the train station up to the
athletic field they started the game
they went down about six runs in the
first inning they came to bat and they
started scoring run after run after run
by the end of the game these Japanese
schoolboys had beaten the Americans at
baseball
the Japanese were not allowed in the
ground
we're ringing the the field and watching
and getting more and more excited after
they won the game the rickshaw drivers
gave them free rides back to the station
they got on the train and the Telegraph
the new telegraph already announced the
news in Tokyo so by the time they
arrived back in Tokyo they were met by
thousands of people and all of their all
of their school where they became
national heroes and that one game sort
of propelled baseball onto the national
consciousness and beating the Americans
at their own sport is really what made
baseball apart from all of the other
sports that they were beginning to play
the most popular sport in Japan and it
went these kids went to university then
they graduated they went out to become
schoolteachers around Japan and they
brought with them their enthusiasm for
baseball so it started percolating down
into the school system and from that
moment really the beginning of the 20th
century baseball was the most popular
the most enthusiastic sport in the
country okay and are there any
differences and how baseball is played
in Japan versus how we play baseball on
this country any distinct differences
well yeah there are a number of
important differences although you know
Freud has this term the uncanny which he
used to talk about things that we look
at something and it looks exactly like
something else except we look again and
it's not quite as sort of uncanny
resemblance that's almost like it and
Japanese baseball is like that you look
at you go to a Japanese baseball game
and you sort of think you're at Fenway
Park and it's the same sport and then
you look closer and it's not quite the
same and part of it is history that is
as I said baseball started as a school
sport like football in the u.s. football
started at Yale and some other places in
the 1870s around the same time so it was
a school sport with a real amateur ethos
to it for a long time before
professional football started became
popular
in the 1950s with television in Japan
the same way baseball was a school sport
it had a very strong sort of amateur
spirit and amateur ethos and then
professional baseball started in the
1930s after a famous tour by Babe Ruth
and Lou Gehrig and so Japanese baseball
has a much more sort of sense of of
trying to be like the amateur game and
trying to not be so professional but it
really is it's also organized somewhat
differently in in the u.s. we've had a
constant expansion of professional teams
in Japan there are only 12 teams in the
two leagues and there are well there's
the Central League and the Pacific
League it was actually modeled on our
American League and the National League
there was one league in the 30s when it
started during World War two baseball
was suspended and then after the war one
of the the first sport that the American
occupation allowed and encouraged the
Japanese to begin again was baseball
except General MacArthur looked at
Japanese baseball he said there's a
problem here because you only have one
league and that's very authoritarian and
we want it to be more American
democratic so you have to have two
leagues so from 1950 they created two
leagues central and Pacific and the
winners of the two leagues meet at the
end of the season we call ours the World
Series they call ours the Japan series
but each of these clubs are owned by
corporations in the u.s. it tends to be
individuals wealthy individuals in Japan
as corporations so they're actually
subsidiaries of corporations and
corporations use them for PR and for
company morale they bring employees to
the games and so teams and the
reputations of teams are supposed to
reflect the reputations of the parent
companies which is sometimes a problem
parent companies don't like teams to
lose because it reflects poorly on their
company so the dynamics are different I
guess the third important element are
the fans if you go to a Japanese
baseball game and the game starts and
all of a sudden it begins to sound like
a Europe
in soccer game there's this organized
non-stop percussive cheering their drums
and trumpets and flags and tier leaders
and tier clubs and it's this cacophony
of noise that starts in the beginning
and doesn't end until the lights go out
in the stadium very different than
American baseball and American fans go
over there and they think this is really
this is not baseball this is something
else and it is something else because
what happened was it's actually American
football
when the Japanese schoolboy team started
coming on exhibitions to the u.s. in the
early 20th century they generally came
in the fall and they were playing
baseball with these American
universities and other teams but on
Saturdays they were going to these
American football games at these
universities stadiums and they were
fascinated by the raccoon coats and the
megaphones and the cheerleaders and they
took careful notes and they went back to
Japan the baseball team did and they got
their baseball team supporters to copy
American football cheering so actually
Japanese baseball games sound more like
American football games than they do
American baseball game and is the season
the same in Japan as it is here longer
shorter it's slightly shorter but
basically the same
they have spring training in February
and they have a preseason and then the
season starts around the same time April
1st finishes in October and they have
their Japan series and the and the u.s.
World Series which is one reason why
there's constant clamor on the Japanese
side to have a true sort of world World
Series between the two countries or
maybe to have American teams play in
Japan and to have a more international
but because the seasons are the same
it's just and the the air you can't get
teams to travel 14 hours to the next
game and the the time difference it's
it's never been feasible but they're
basically the same the same seasons and
the same sense of seasonality
okay and what about the contracts and
money how does that work well again
because it's more corporate these are
these also the players were not
considered corporate employees they were
sort of employees of these subsidiary
companies they had it took Japanese
baseball a lot longer than American
baseball to have things like free agency
and agents and multi-year contracts so
even today professional baseball players
are probably paid at roughly a half to a
third what they can make in the US which
is why some of the stars are coming over
here regularly
year after year what about some of the
other sports in Japan well I guess sumo
would be the most the second sport
certainly most known outside of Japan
and sumos roots go back way into
prehistory it was a more of a temple
ritual sport and again in the late 19th
century it too became a sort of a
national Japanese sport but it's always
been a more specialized and a more
cloistered sport
there are stables of wrestlers that are
operated by former wrestlers it's done
in a stadium that's rather expensive in
the tickets and rather hard to get to
public television broadcasted and not
the commercial network so it's always
been something of a special sport for
both those who would wrestle and also
for that for the spectators so they have
a special but nobody else practises sumo
so it hasn't really spread okay so it's
not really as popular to the masses as
baseball I mean its popular but the
levels of spectatorship and the levels
of enthusiasm are far less than that for
baseball and soccer is making huge
strides all around the world of course
it's the main sport in many countries
and in the United States it's really
taken off is it does it have any role in
Japan very much so and it's it's also
like the United States in the 20
century soccer was as marginal in Japan
as it was in the u.s. it was played in
schools and a couple of companies had
soccer teams but it was completely
overshadowed by baseball and sumo and
some of the other sports but by the end
of the 20th century soccer is the global
game Japan wants to be a global player
East Asia wants to be a global player so
not just Japan but Korea and Taiwan and
certainly China all of a sudden wanted
to participate more in this global game
and Japan I mean it has geopolitical
connotations Japan wanted to move away
from us Japan relationship and more to a
global positioning and so soccer has
taken on that that meaning in Japan as
as the global game they have a
professional league that started in the
90s and like the u.s. it's had trouble
getting traction but it's actually
stronger in Japan than in the u.s.
Japanese players are going to Europe to
play in the Premier League's
in Europe there's a lot of satellite
broadcasting of European soccer games
into Japan the country the country's
become soccer mad you look at kids in
high school and all of a sudden the
soccer teams are becoming as popular as
the baseball teams sort of like in
places in parts of the US where the
soccer teams are drawing more of the
athletes than some of the football teams
so it's I think it's really important
the other importance is soccer in East
Asia where tensions are rising in China
and Japan are contesting in Korea and
Taiwan don't want to be left behind
baseball is not a sport in which you can
play out the East Asian rivalries now
you can't play baseball with China or
baseball even with Korea you can't you
can't play judo or the martial arts
soccer is the sport where all of the
East Asian nations can play each other
at their fiercest most competitive
I mean it really is is a is a breeder of
kind of sports nationalism in East Asia
and I think that's that's another reason
and I think yet another reason is gender
that is there's baseball but women are
not allowed to play baseball they play
softball and actually Japanese women's
softball team has been world champions
it's quite good but it's not played much
in schools soccer is the one major sport
where women can play women's T in the
Japanese women's soccer team won the the
Women's World Cup this year they're
really powerful and so within the
country I think soccer is becoming
popular among the younger generation for
for also because girls can play soccer
in school and girls now have role models
among the elite women soccer players and
the Women's World Cup is becoming much
more of a of a high visible sort of
global event so I think you know
baseball and sumo were Japan's 20th
century sports but there's a strong
likelihood that soccer is going to be
Japan's 21st century sport you mentioned
earlier that some of the baseball
players would go to watch American
football games and took back the
cheering to the baseball games I am
curious to know if you have any thoughts
as to do they play football in Japan at
all and if they do why do you think it
hasn't taken off to the extent that
baseball has well it hasn't taken off
because baseball smothered all sports
not just American football it is a
popular sport at certain in certain
university leagues that is it remained
like rugby rugby is also popular like it
is in the u.s. in university clubs and
one interesting feature of sports in
Japan is that corporations have played a
much more important role in sponsoring
sports and organizing sports teams than
in the US or in Europe so all the major
corporations from the throughout the
second half of the 20th century had
baseball teams and basketball teams
and some American football teams for
their employees and they would actually
recruit employees to play on their
sports teams and there were
inter-corporate leagues so that like IBM
and Ford and Chevrolet would play would
have a basketball league or an ice
hockey league or swimming where they had
a wide range of sports and so Japan's I
mean things like the Olympic development
in Japan was largely due to and fed by
this corporate investment in sports and
sports teams and so things like rugby
and American football have found have
survived as niche sports sports in these
elite universities and in some of these
big corporations but by and large big
kids get channeled into sumo and the
rest of them get channeled into baseball
when I think of Japan and sports a lot
of times I go to the martial arts and
you had mentioned judo how is that
what's the status of judo in Japan today
well the ironic thing is do those an
individual sport and baseball is a team
sport and we always think of the
Japanese is very collectivist very group
but back in the 1870s 1880s the Ministry
of educators knew Ministry of Education
looked around and said we have a problem
in our school system our kids are not
not getting physically strong they're
weak we need to do something and and
they said we have a choice we can either
encourage judo and martial arts or we
can encourage some Western sports and
said we don't want these Japanese
they're too individualistic we want the
American sports in the in the British
sports because they teach teamplay and
so judo and the other martial arts
actually were not as encouraged in Japan
in the school system and as popular
pursuits but judo interestingly as
Japan's first global sport that is judo
from the 1920s there were a couple of
the impact the fellow who
in effect created invented judo out of a
number of different indigenous martial
arts traditions then went to the United
States it went to South America went to
Europe and brought judo so judo traveled
really around the world from the 1920s
on as Japan's contribution to the 20th
century sports inventory and the key
moment in the moment that really shocked
the Japanese was in 1964 when the Tokyo
Olympics were held that first time the
Olympics ever came to Asia and Tokyo
this was Tokyo Japan's coming-out party
after World War two they were going to
demonstrate that they had recovered that
they were a normal nation and they had a
couple of star judo players in the in
the the heavyweight or the the open
weight category the Japanese star lost
to a dutch judo master and this shocked
the Japanese in their own sport and all
it did was to say the judo had become
fully globalized at that point so judo
exists in Japan but the the the
international judo organization is not
in Japan it's in Europe and judo is is
much more of a global sport now because
of its basically Japan's gift to 20th
century sport what do you think is the
future of sports in Japan well it's hard
to predict I mean certainly Japan China
East Asia is the most dynamic sports
market in the world now in terms of
sports marketing in terms of sports
promotion and you look at soccer and you
look at the Olympics you look at golf
and you look at a number of a track and
field even so in East Asia generally it
will be probably the most dynamic growth
area for sports in the next couple
decades and the Japanese consume sports
as as avidly as people anywhere they
watch baseball although increasingly
they're watching our baseball rather
than their own baseball they're
certainly watching soccer from all over
the world sports that aren't that
important in the u.s. like auto racing
I'm very popular in Japan so it's part
of the International f1 auto racing
circuit horse racing is popular in Japan
so they've connected in ways with sports
around the world that actually don't
necessarily mean that sports will grow
in Japan but certainly sports
consciousness and sports markets and
sports enthusiasm and sports nationalism
for better or worse will be important in
Japan for the foreseeable future this
has been really interesting thanks so
much for being here very much enjoyed
your work for more information about
professor kelly and his work please
visit our website at yale.edu backslash
macmillan report be sure to join us
again for another episode of the
Macmillan report made possible through
funding from the Whitney and Betty
Macmillan Center for International and
area studies at Yale